[Musik]
willkommen bei unserem allerersten
podcast der auch nur 15 minuten lang
geht aber dafür dicht und gut ist hallo
marcel ja schön dass du da bist
heute ist das thema künstliche
intelligenz wir fangen wir mit ein paar
beispielen an damit wir wissen wovon wir
reden
hast du beispiele für künstlich ja ich
meine wir sehen im alltag immer mehr
künstler intelligenz wie sie uns
begleitet das fängt zum beispiel an mit
dem smartphone mit dieser neuen google
funktion google lens mit du ganz einfach
bestimmte gegenstände fotografieren
kannst und google jens sagt zu sein um
was es sich dabei handelt oder es
erkennt texte die im alltag vorkommen
dann gibt es die neuen schadprogramme
die sehr intelligent sind und die ganz
hohe elo zahl erreichen die besten
schachspieler schlagen dann gibts sowas
wie texterkennung und gesichtserkennung
und nicht zuletzt autonomes fahren was
immer wichtiger wird wo man sich zum
beispiel fragen kann brauchen wir
zukunft überhaupt noch taxifahrerinnen
und taxifahrer oder fährt und dass
sachsen nicht alleine von einem ort zum
ziel und manövriert auch staus oder
baustellen das ist alles in greifbare
nähe
ja und da reden wir ja heutzutage von
künstlicher intelligenz die frage oder
beziehungsweise das problem was wir
erwarten ist eigentlich gar nicht
bestimmen zu können was erstmal
intelligenz ist und zweitens sind diese
dinge vielleicht wirklich noch gar nicht
intelligente algorithmen die neuronalen
netzwerke wie sie letztlich sprach
warten also woran können wir intelligenz
an sich beurteilen und erkennen
das ist ein sehr guter punkt wo wir als
philosophen und philosophen ins spiel
kommen bei dieser neuen entwicklung
philosophie sollte er immer auch was zur
gegenwärtigen problematik sagen und ich
meine du hast jetzt 1 genannt
intelligenz es gibt noch verschiedene
andere formen von systemischen als
erkenntnistheoretischen phänomenen oder
akt
die solchen systemen zugesprochen werden
neben intelligenz erkennen dann kann man
noch sagen lernen sie merken sich etwas
die vernetzen sie erinnern sie wissen
sie verstehen sie denken sie begreifen
sie stellen sich etwas vor und sich
entscheiden oder handeln sogar das führt
dazu dass das system am ende sogar als
ein akteur als ein subjekt interpretiert
wird und hier müssen wir philosophen und
philosoph natürlich kritisch die ganze
sache betrachten weil es handelt sich um
einen gegenstand und nicht so sehr um
ein subjekt also wir neigen als menschen
immer dazu anderen dingen oder anderen
ja wissen menschliche eigenschaften
unterzuschieben zb neigen häufig dazu
auch tieren irgendwelche menschlichen
emotionen
das ist also ein anthroposophisch muss
das ist typisch menschliche akt sie mir
kennen das alle der der hund hat jetzt
darüber gelacht oder findet das ironisch
das soll nicht heißen dass tiere nicht
auch ironie empfinden können aber wir
neigen dazu es häufiger anzuwenden
dort wo es vielleicht gar nicht ist und
genauso gehen wir auch vor wenn es sich
nicht um tiere handelt sondern eben
computer oder um neuronale künstliche
neuronale netze wir können nicht anders
als sie uns so zu denken als ob sie mit
nach menschlichen mustern funktionieren
würde
und vor diesem hintergrund dieses andere
profis muss der einerseits vorteile
bietet weil wir dinge eben leichter
immer erkennen können weil sie uns enel
aber weil wir eben auch dingen etwas
unterstellen oder hineinprojizieren
sollten wir diese ganzen begriffe im
umkreis der künstlichen intelligenz sehr
problematisieren und jetzt fragt hast du
ja kann so ein system überhaupt erkennen
das ist hängt natürlich davon ab was du
unter erkennt verstehen ja vielleicht
können wir
ganz grob erstmal die chemischen
phänomene durchgehend die neuronale
netze und dass die sogenannten
künstlichen intelligenz unserer heutigen
zeit eigentlich beherrschen also genau
also künstliche neuronale netze sind
mittlerweile oder momentan dasjenige was
wenn es überhaupt künstliche intelligenz
gibt die höchste intelligenz hat diese
neuronalen netze stehen hinter diesen
ganzen phänomen die ich vorhin erklärt
hatte die kälte und gesichtserkennung
genau oder ganz allgemein musste
erkennen
dahinter stehen die wir haben im seminar
wird macht da oben den linken oben
rechts in der seminar sitzung haben hat
uns ausführlich damit beschäftigt wie
die funktionieren also wer mir sagen das
sind systeme zum muster erkennen
dann würde ich schon sagen dass es sich
hierbei um eine gewisse form von
urteilskraft hand also immanuel kant
unterscheide zwischen der bestimmenden
und der reflektierenden urteilskraft und
die bestimmende urteilskraft meint dass
wir ein gegebenes phänomen unter eine
gegebene kategorie subsumieren müssen
wir wissen aber nicht unter welche
kategorie genau weil wir viele
kategorien haben und eine richtige
zuordnung von einzelphänomen und ein
muster das nennt man auch klassifizieren
und das ist eigentlich ein typischer
kenntnis akt den wir selbst täglich
vollbringen was ist da noch mal gegeben
also das ist das allgemeinen gegeben
oder das seite des beides frei das ist
beides gegeben also wir haben
verschiedene allgemeinen type gibt typen
gegeben zb könnten wir neuronales netz
darauf trainieren
rosen von tulpen zu unterscheiden da
müssen wir eben die das muster rosenthal
begeben
als allgemeine muster begriff könnte man
auch sagen und dann verschiedene bilder
zb könnte auch sagen wie sie gerüche ist
ganz egal welche daten in das neuronale
netz einspeisen
und er müsste man halt jeweils immer
sagen dieses system ja das ist jetzt
eine tolle und das ist eine große uni
besser dieser klassifizierung
funktioniert umso mehr sind wir
nike diese neuronalen netz intelligenz
zuzusprechen und ich denke die guten
gründen ja vielleicht weil wir da schon
sind können wir ja noch kurz erklären
den zuhörern wie eigentlich eine
klassifizierung für das netz kurz
funktioniert also das hat ja wie du
gerade gesagt hast ein input an daten
und nach diesem input macht es irgendwas
und dann hat es ein output und zwar
diese bestimmung von rosen und tulpen
genauer spielen
also es wird es im pott outputs systemen
und könnte auch sagen ein bisschen black
box was da in der mitte stattfindet das
10 wir meistens nicht deswegen spricht
man auch mal solche neuronalen netzen
von sogenannten hitlers also versteckten
schichten die dann wenn sie in der fall
sind auch das ganze system zum dieb
learning system machen also wenn das
zwischen schichten zwischen input und
output schicht gibt und dass die burning
also wir kriegen ihn vor drei und wir
haben so künstlichen ronan das sind also
rezeptoren könnte man sagen oder auch
sender zugleich die eben erst ab einem
bestimmten schwellenwert in gang gesetzt
werden also wenn die informationen die
eingehend sehr gering sind dann
reagieren die gar nicht und zwar aus
gutem grund hat man uns im gehirn
nachgebildet weil unser gehirn sind
überlastet wäre wären zu viele daten
genau einfach wahrgenommen
genau oder daten rauschen es gibt so
viel information und wie man kennt das
häufig bei scans wenn es dann so staub
gibt oder so schwarze punkte häufig
werden die dann deutlich als punkte
erkannt und ist dann sehr ärgerlich und
als kommas man will die einfach
ignorieren und dafür sind diese
sogenannten aktivierungscode wenn dich
die am festlegen ab welchem wert
überhaupt der prozess in gang gesetzt
wird genau und wir haben eben zwischen
diesen verschiedenen rohn verschiedene
gewicht ton also wie die informationen
im übergang von neuronen zu wohnen oder
von schicht zu schicht gewichtet werden
und diese gewichtungen sind parameter
war oder auch variablen die wir immer
mehr verbessern können und an diesen
gewicht tun dieses netzwerkes können wir
es trainieren um den besten output zu
bringen
und wenn der output es nicht gut ist
also von dem sollwert abweicht also wenn
der jetzt eben nicht die rose erkennst
und eben die tulpe dann schafft es ein
künstliches neuronales netz dass dieser
fehler wert wieder zurückgenommen wird
also rückgekoppelt wird und wieder neu
eingespeist wird und so gibt es einen
permanenten kreislauf eine optimierungs
kreislauf bis am ende eben dieses system
so gut eingestellt oder gelernt hat das
ist eben sehr zuverlässige musste
erkennungsleistung vollzieht ok danke
also das ist im prinzip können wir sagen
ein neuronales netz was wir auf
schuldner rose erkennung trainieren muss
erst mal 10 20 30 vielleicht sogar 40
verschiedene bilder oder noch mehr an
tulpen und rosen gesehen dass sie
hinhaben du bringst du guten punkt ist
natürlich wieder metaphorisch geredet
oder andere anderen touristisch wir
können eigentlich gar nicht anders über
dieses thema reden als aus und sind auch
in begriffen also man könnte sagen wir
müssen ist mit daten füttern
aber auch das ist wieder eine antwort
home office muss das hat natürlich kein
hunger
diesen runden mit müssen eine gewisse
datengrundlage zur verfügung haben
genauer auf das dann dieses system
trainiert wird ja also ich will noch
einmal kurz zusammenfassen wir haben
jetzt verschiedene muslimische phänomen
beschrieben die in der ohne alles netz
macht und zwar eines das tulpen und
rosen erkennen kann
so ist es nämlich aber auch bei bild
gesichtserkennung und dabei autonom
vergönnt und das waren jetzt die
folgenden phänomene erkennen lernen es
kann sich etwas merken aber auch an
drohungen ausgesprochen
es kann vernetzen und erinnern
vielleicht und jetzt ist die frage jetzt
kommen wir zum ticket point kann es was
wissen verstehen kann es denken und
dinge mit greifen
das sind das sind wirklich höher stufige
phänomene wo wir wirklich aufpassen
müssen die diesen system zu unterstellen
weil selbst viele tiere nicht dazu in
der lage sind zum beispiel zum denken
also denken musste zum beispiel jetzt
begriffe voraus setzt voraus dass wir
den semantischen gehalt also die
bedeutung auch verstehen dass kommt
wieder zum nächsten begriff und jetzt
kann man sich wirklich fragen ob ein
künstliches neurosen rund neuronales
netz diese kategorien wirklich versteht
versteht es vielleicht gewisse
beziehungen herzustellen dass das eine
und das andere fällt aber damit ist noch
nicht gesagt dass das neuronale netz
weiß was ein hund ist es weiß nur dass
wenn es irgend etwas bekommen hat dieses
muster der derart genau ist ein muster
dieser dieser dieser art aber ob es
damit auch eine bedeutung ein sind
gottlob krieges sagen würde verbindet
das scheint mir sehr fraglich zu sein
also das ist problematisch und genauso
auch entscheiden also entscheiden heißt
eigentlich mehr als nur oder b
entscheiden meint immer auch
irgendwelche gründe mit ins spiel zu
bringen und bei seiner klassifizierungs
leistung ob jetzt dass eine rose tulpe
ist da sind keine gründe spiele sind da
geht es ihr einfach um ein perfektes
sehr flexibles muster erkennungssystem
was zum beispiel rose die mal aus einem
anderen blickwinkel fotografiert wurde
eben immer noch als rose anzieht und
wenn wir uns vor die frage stellen was
entscheidend bedeutet dann spielen wir
immer gründe eine rolle also auch eine
gewisse form von werten von interessen
die wir selbst besitzen
und ich glaube nicht dass eine und alles
netz ein künstliches wirklich interessen
besitzt auf basis dessen ist dann in
gang gesetzt wird oder sich selbst in
gang setzt sind die interessen werden
diesen künstlichen neuronalen netz immer
von uns vorgegeben also jetzt
unterscheidet doch mal zwischen rosen
und tulpen
aber es ein neuronales netz kenne wohl
nie von sich selbst auf die idee jetzt
mal die eingangsdaten mal nach anderen
kategorien zu betrachten die ihm nicht
vorher eingegeben wurden also sowas wie
ein eigeninteresse oder auch wie ein
problembewusstsein scheint eben
künstlichen neuronalen netzen zu fehlen
und das führt mich zum wichtigsten punkt
ich glaube eben dass damit ein system
wirklich intelligent genannt werden kann
es lebendig sein muss sprich in der lage
sein muss
genuine eigeninteressen auszubilden die
ihm nicht hetero- nom also von außen
vorgegeben sind seien autonom in ihm
selbst liegen und solche eigeninteressen
diana autonomen könnte haben eben nur
lebewesen dazu gehört zum beispiel die
überlebenstrieb dass ich einfach gerade
fragen also welche war was sind das denn
für für gründe motivation das was es
denn intrinsischen uns was uns antreibt
und bewegt also zum einmal zb unser
überlebenstrieb also wir wollen eben
nicht dass wenn wir irgendwie krank sind
dass die krankheit das weiter ausbreitet
wir wollen auch nicht eingeschränkt
werden unseren lebens vollzügen wenn man
uns droht den kleinen finger
abzuschneiden dann wollen wir das
verhindern wenn man uns eine kleine
wunde einem kleinen pieks zu versetzt
dann heilt der körper sich in der regel
selbst kann neuronales netzwerk nicht
wenn man dem nur den vergleich ziehen
wenn man in dem stecker aussieht und das
merkt das nicht erstens dass wir das
vorhaben den tier was wir zur schlacht
bringen und das wird sich auch nicht so
ich will genau
oder wenn man schon neuronalen netz und
künstlichen so einen layer rausnimmt so
eine ganze schicht von verona auch hier
ein neuron auspackt dann wird sich
dieses neuro nicht dagegen sperren oder
es wird das ist künstliche system wird
kein 099 erzeugen so wie sie sich bei
uns die zellen regeneriert genau also
solche solche strukturen bräuchten hier
ich bin jetzt mir nicht sicher ob es
vielleicht eine zukunft möglich wäre das
ein neuronales netz zugangs auch selbst
entwickelt weil wir ja eine gewisse
analogie des neuronalen netzes des
künstlichen zum leben haben nämlich
dasjenige das es selbst bezüglich ist
oder sie
geschlossen ist dieses diese output
dieser fehler output wird wieder neu
eingespeist und da gibt es immer wieder
ein kreislauf und an dieser kreislauf
struktur könnte man ansetzen die müssen
natürlich viel komplexer sein dass
irgendwann auch so eine art
eigeninteresse im agiert aber das
scheint mir nach rückgängen der zukunft
ist aber von der grund operation scheint
es zumindest möglich denkbar
dann würden wir das jetzt einfach mal
abschließen geben derzeit und wir haben
ja auch schon einige sätze gesprochen
sinnvoll durch nicht verständlich
hoffentlich auch ja also welche welche
art von intelligenz würdest du einem
neuronalen netz oder einer künstlichen
intelligenz wenn es die gäbe zu
schreiben das wäre notwendig was wäre
möglich heutzutage ja zuletzt als ich
würde
viele dieser aufgelisteten phänomen in
diesem neuronalen netz zu sprechen aber
eben nur in einem relativen sinne oder
einem hypothetischen sind damit meine
ich folgendes diaz intelligenz formen
treten nur dann auf wenn überhaupt nur
dann entstehen beim künstlichen
neuronalen jetzt wenn wir ihm das
interesse oder das problem vorgegeben
haben
nur unter dieser bedingung dass es von
außen vorgeben wird können dann gewisse
intelligenz formen wie zum beispiel
klassifizieren usw vorgenommen werden
also zum beispiel wäre ich in diesem
hypothetischen sinne bereit einem
neuronalen netz so was wie die
erkenntnis funktion zu zu sprechen wenn
die klassifizierungs funktion wie eine
merck finck zion wieder vernetzungs
funktionen wie eine erinnerungsfunktion
vielleicht sogar auch wie eine begreift
funktion
spannend wird es nämlich dann wenn es um
neuronale netze geht die sowas wie
übersetzungsleistungen vollziehen ich
darf ja an die pr erinnern die beton
komm in meinen augen wirklich ich werde
jetzt nicht davon bezahlt eines der
besten übersetzungsprogramme war es eine
unglaublich gute ergebnisse hervorbringt
von setzen die es davor noch nicht
gekannt hatte als man kann da setzte
einspeisen und es übersetzt die und
macht das wirklich neu und da
mir wirklich auch so eine gewisse ja es
um taktisch und sein taktisches gespür
schon fast im hintergrund sein und die
ergebnisse sind wirklich erstaunlich ok
und jetzt um die science fiction angst
[Musik]
spekulation irgendwie vielleicht zu
entnehmen
würde ich könnte ich jetzt
zusammenfassen können wir sagen dass
eine künstliche intelligenz mit
bestimmten parametern und einem ganz
konkreten ziel
neue ziele entwickelt aus sich selbst
heraus suchen zum beispiel dass ein
computer der bisher irgendwie dafür
verantwortlich war alle daten zu
analysieren dass der aus dem nichts auf
einmal die menschheit auslöschen möchte
das ist ja heutzutage und mit der art
und weise ist gerade definiert haben er
nicht möglich war warum ich meine du
hast jetzt ein dritter interessantes
neues stichwort gebracht nämlich möchte
oder der wille
also wir haben jetzt hier dieses
phänomen noch gar nicht aufgelistet weil
es auch kein genuines systemisches
phänomen ist der wille aber das ist der
nächste punkt keine der wille ist da
dachte ich jetzt irgend bezug auf
zielsetzung richtig okay so im sinne
dieses zwei kästen zweck wie die
menschheit auszulöschen
das würde genau neuronales netz oder
künstliche intelligenz momentan auch gar
nicht zu schreiben es wäre eben dieses
problem dass es eben bislang immer den
zweck von außen braucht und wenn es aber
selbst der lage wären neue zwecke sich
zu setzen
dann wäre das natürlich eine mögliche
problematik dass so ein zweck gesetzt
werden könnte aber man müsste ich mir
überlegen warum wird so ein zweck
gesetzt und dazu müssen wir die gründe
im spiel sein
man kann das natürlich weiter spielen
und in einem gewissen
optimierungsprozess sich fundiert denken
dass gewisse extrapolation als
erweiterungen eines bereits bestehenden
systems zu neuen zielen führen können
man gibt ihm ein ziel vor
und das system sie dann aber ich muss
das ziel eigentlich selbst korrigieren
und das ziel verändern
aber es muss auf jeden fall anfangs
input gegeben sei
man weiß natürlich nicht wohin das ganze
führt wenn man mal ein ziel
einprogrammiert und das system so clever
ist dass das ziel selbst dann verändert
also sich selbst eigene vorgaben neue
setzt aber das sehe ich momentan noch
keine basis drauf aber wenn es der fall
wäre dann hätten wir es wirklich mit
einem nicht nur hypothetischen
systemischen aktie tun so mit einem
druck absoluten und dann könnten wir von
freiheit oder auch autonomie sprechen
und dann würde unsere ethik völlig
revolutioniert werden und nicht nur
unsere ethik unsere gesamte philosophie
des geistes und und theologie natürlich
auch vielen dank
spannende dinge erscheint die zeit
reicht immer nicht aus aber dann freue
ich mich auf die nächste folge wo wir
über ein nächstes thema im ganzen
bereich digitalität treten bis nichts
danke tschüss
[Musik]